new year
new me
same old woke commercials that's right
you send them in
and i do my best i use all my expert
analytical powers
to guess
what actual product
these woke corporations are selling in
their extremely
politically
driven
advertisements so you've sent in some
new ones
we have four here
i'm going to start out this year on the
right track i want to i want to get all
of them
i want to bat a thousand today this
video is sponsored by expressvpn more
from them in a second let's let's get
right to the commercials
healthcare workers really challenging
for me this is going to be like um
ppe some like ppe kind nope google it's
google
i think
the search might be kind of cheating
[Music]
but it's kind of a generic search bar so
i guess it could have been another one
for some reason i'm having anxiety
obviously it's normal with everything
that's going on right now i think
they're gonna take a break
google also owns like everything now so
there's a greater reward on the other
side
there is a fair chance you know i'm just
trying to do my little part to try and
save my community
[Music]
i'm just really excited we're back open
and i am
[Applause]
it's also kind of multimedia so it's
like yeah welcome back to the theater
that you can
watch from your couch from your pod
from your isolation
[Music]
we the jury in the above entitled matter
as to count three find the defendant
guilty
[Applause]
[Music]
we just have to band together as a
community and get people's lives back
they're really milking this one grew
that even as we hurt we hoped that even
as we tired we tried
how to stop asian hate
and then they have a blm right after
that she's like well uh
there might be a relationship here
between these two things search on is
this is google
yeah baby okay it was kind of cheating
because they had the google search bar
although look all the search bars look
kind of similar
baton a thousand here we go bring me the
next one
[Music]
earpiece
or like a music thing
but please do pay attention because we
will be having a test on this one
[Applause]
[Music]
some kind of music thing i think
because they had the earpiece in the
beginning
every day
[Music]
like that sweater
[Music]
in other news cases of anxiety and young
adults arising as experts warn of the
effects on well-being caused by the
pandemic for more on this we
no it's not from the pandemic it's from
these lunatics locking everyone up in
their tiny apartments for two years
and keeping kids out of school
the virus didn't do that it's like you
guys did that
[Music]
i really have no idea
if it's not a music thing which is uh
just just because there's music playing
and i saw that your pieces
[Music]
as as people's anxiety and depression
are rising
because of being locked up from the
pandemic stay home and just order more
stuff that'll make you feel better stuff
stuff stuff don't see anybody or go out
or do anything just sit in your pod and
order more crap that you don't need
i know i did suspect that whatever
product was being sold it was something
that was going to lock people up in
their homes
because that's just all anyone's selling
now is just stay home buy virtually
don't leave give us your money i like
money the pandemic has been awful for
young people so we need to exacerbate
the largest transfer of wealth from the
lower to the wealthier classes in human
history that's that'll solve it
when you are stuck at home as so many of
us are make sure that you don't browse
the internet without using expressvpn
using the internet without expressvpn is
like leaving your laptop exposed at the
coffee shop table while you run to the
bathroom most of the time you're
probably going to be fine but what if
one day you come out of the bathroom and
your laptop is gone every time you
connect to an unencrypted network cafes
hotels airports any hacker on the same
network can gain access to your personal
data your passwords your financial
details etc does not take much technical
knowledge to hack someone just some
cheap hardware is needed a smart 12 year
old could do it your data is valuable
hackers can make up to a thousand bucks
per person selling personal info on the
dark web right now you go to expressvpn
you get that encrypted tunnel it creates
a secure connection you have to protect
your data fire up the app it's super
easy you click on one button you get
protected works on all devices phones
laptops tablets and more stay secure i
love it i don't go online without
expressvpn on my devices secure your
online data today go to expressvpn.com
michael yt
expressvpn.com michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l-y-t
you get an extra three months free at
expressvpn.com
michael y t
baton 500
give me the next one
medusa lived with the hideous curse
i mean the whole turning people to stone
thing was a bit of a buzzkill right so
she ordered sunglasses with prime one
day delivery
i didn't have a lot of time to guess on
that one
people realize she's actually hilarious
once you get to know her
is this woke does this count as woke
but he was asking who was this woke he
changed everything
i guess it's woke in the sense that
wokeness just tries to invert reality so
men are women and bad is good and up is
down and ugly is beautiful dogs and cats
living together so if the commercial is
rehabilitating medusa i guess
it's a stretch that i don't want that to
count against me
one because the logo came up too soon
but two that's not
there are plenty of woke woken enough
commercials we don't we don't need to
reach like that
so
if i'm not going to count that then that
means we're 50 50.
i don't care what the judges say we're
50 50. give me the tiebreaker give me
the bonus here here we go
remember mom is a kayak denier so please
don't bring it up
here we go
excuse me
is this kayak like the
research todd the airline website
kayak searches hundreds of travel sites
to find you great deals on flights cars
and hotels they're lying to you who's
they kayak
[Music]
open your eyes
compare hundreds of travel sites at once
kayak search one and done yeah
yeah you idiots hahaha do you know that
there are some people out there who
don't just believe everything that the
corporate globalist liberal
establishment tells them
idiots just believe whatever fauci says
even though dr fauci contradicts himself
every other day you're a
donut you're so stupid no guys just look
the the global
liberal establishment tells us that we
have global cooling so just what are you
a science denier idiot just believe them
sorry hold on i'm uh new information
it's global warming now what are you a
dummy you don't even believe in glo oh
sorry um no it's climate change
what are you a dumb idiot you don't even
believe that the world is going to end
in like 12 years oops said okay nope
sorry we already got past that so it's
going to be but it'll be another 12
years what are you a dummy so yeah
that's a very woke commercial but come
on got producers
they said kayak within
five seconds of the commercial starting
you cannot expect me i'm i am pretty
good at this
all right i've gotten better at least
over the years
but i'm i don't have reflexes like that
okay that was too fast
i know it counts against me i get i get
what am i 333 that's still enough to get
me into the baseball hall of fame
but give me a chance
at least to get back into this in 2022
if you've got any vote commercials
please send them in we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you